hello internet welcome to film theory
where i am 100 totally matpat and not
some deep faked talking picture of him
ain't that right obama yes that's right
my good friend matpat
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that hopes to one day be hosted
by an ai generated assemblage of vocal
lines gathered from the past 10 years of
video uploads that's not even a joke i'm
being absolutely serious i'm just a
talking cutout how much easier could it
be for a computer to just make this
stuff up while i'm off relaxing on a
beach somewhere anyway before we get
into the meat and potatoes of today's
theory i wanted to start things off with
a little story about a long forgotten
movie back in 2002 new line cinema
released a sci-fi comedy named simone or
s-1-0
some tells me that mainstream audiences
of 2002 weren't super comfortable with
leet speak anyway this film starred al
pacino as a frustrated over-the-hill
movie director whose latest project goes
to heck when his lead actress quits in
the middle of filming fortunately his
software genius friend leaves him with
this experimental computer animation
software for generating photorealistic
humans and thus simone the perfect
actress is born good morning good
morning mister
a star
is digitized and people buy it in fact
people buy it too well she becomes the
hottest most beloved star in the world
so now he has to generate fake
interviews fake publicity events she
ties with herself at the oscars she even
has a live appearance using hologram
technology that would put hatsune miku
to shane eventually he gets sick of it
all and tries to turn the whole thing
off by telling people the truth and no
one believes him he gets accused of
simone's murder forgive me mr
i'm just trying to understand here now
all these films and tv appearances all
fake
i you understand perfectly and the uh
fan club with worldwide membership in
the millions that's also
bogus no the fan club's real what they
were worshiping is a computer code ones
and zeros eventually his family
reactivates the simone program to help
clear his name and from there they take
the next logical step why stop at one
character when you can have a whole cast
you have to finish what you started
simone has a family cgi baby and all why
do i bring all that up i don't know i
suppose you could say it's been on my
mind recently at the conclusion of its
second season the mandalorian brought
back young luke skywalker using a
combination of body double digital
de-aging effects facial capture
animation and real-time face and voice
replacement software it is deep fake
luke a walking talking cgi puppet man
that can say and do whatever you want
him to do sure the tech wasn't fully out
of the uncanny valley but you know it
was still an impressive moment that
provided a cool big reveal and they were
smart enough to keep it short so it
wouldn't distract from get back up
always get back up oh okay he's back for
yet another cameo his name was yoda he
was small like you
but his heart was huge okay so virtual
luke returned in a big way during the
recent mandalorian season 2.5 uh sorry i
mean the book of we already forgot the
show was supposed to be about that other
helmet guy and not just return either
luke had practically an entire episode
to himself don't try
do size matters not will i see you again
have you heard anyone talk like that
back home you're trying too hard nope
i'm not the one trying too hard here
luke just saying and while luke
skywalker's walking cgi pup has been
getting more and more on screen time
he's not the only one more and more
famous actors are getting digitally
de-aged for the better all
across the universe or for the worse not
in the cards but what's even more
noteworthy and creepy and also
concerning from an ethical standpoint is
the higher volume of dead actors that
are being brought back to life using the
exact same technology i thought you
could leave not saying goodbye
i thought you might turn up what is it
they've sent us
hope so today i want to look at this
trend why is this happening and
specifically why is this happening now
because spoiler alert this exact thing
used to be hollywood's biggest fear a
decade or two ago but now for whatever
reason the technology seems to be
getting shoved down everyone's throats
why is that and from there i also want
to expose you to some of the more
disturbing elements of the trend like
did you know that disney's developing a
whole human library of this stuff and
how none of it may actually require
permission from the original actors so
strap in as we explore the dystopian
future that's slowly evolving around us
this one is a doozy so first it's
important to understand exactly what
we're talking about here when it comes
to digitally de-aging or even full-on
resurrecting dead actors there are three
basic ways that you can take it the
first is a completely computer-generated
version of a person based on scans and
footage they are literally walking
talking video game characters that have
been inserted into movie scenes believe
it or not but everyone's favorite
undercover sith lord jar jar binks he
was the earliest motion captured cgi
character back in 1999
the character you just love to force
choke pretty unbelievable how far we've
come in the past 20 years gollum from
lord of the rings came shortly
afterwards in 2001. that same year final
fantasy the spirits within it released
with a full cast of quote-unquote photo
realistic 3d animated actors this thing
was such a big deal that the female lead
of the movie aki ross actually got an
officially licensed swimsuit spread in
max magazine's hot 100. she even came in
at the respectable number 87. was that
the bikini of 87 and thus the concept of
synthespians was born synthetic
thespians fast forward to today and the
technology has gotten so advanced that
it's what's been used to resurrect peter
cushing to reprise his role as grand
moff tarkin in rogue one the second
route is using this tech almost like you
would make up or a prosthetic back in
the day where it's used to airbrush out
things like wrinkles this de-aging tech
has been used to let actors like robert
deniro and joe pesci play the same
characters across decades of time in the
irishman same with d aging samuel l
jackson for captain marvel and michael
douglas for flashbacks in the ant-man
movies it can also be used in reverse
aging up chris evans to be old captain
america and endgame see the difference
of him just in the makeup versus him
with the cgi boost pretty cool lastly
you have deep fake which is the most
complicated of the bunch here you feed a
bunch of old photos and footage into a
computer to build out a library of
expressions in different lighting
scenarios hairstyles whatever then you
have a real actor performed through the
scene but all the while a complex neural
network figures out how to replace their
face with a series of photos pulled from
that image library based on stuff like
eye line lighting and expression and
from there the team can fine-tune all
the details is the likeness on target so
we would experiment with different
things we would change the hair we would
put the hair over the ears we would have
it at full further behind his neck we
would change his neck size we'll bring
his collar up we'll bring his shoulders
down but what's most incredible about
all this isn't the evolution of the
technology it's actually the changing
attitude of hollywood towards using the
technology when simone hit theaters the
concept of flesh and blood actors having
to compete for roles against
synthespians was a big cause for concern
especially for the screen actors guild
it was quite literally one of these
situations and now these people from the
future are showing up and offering to do
the same work for next to nothing they
took our jobs for as silly as all this
might sound an army of digital actors
replacing real actors it's important to
remember the context here in 2000 and
2001 actors in hollywood were in this
huge fight the screen actors guild was
in the midst of a major contract
renegotiation with the rest of the
industry one that was on the verge of an
industry crippling labor strike you see
at the time big stars like julia roberts
tom cruise jim carrey will smith and
halle berry were what made the
blockbuster system run a whole movie
could just be marketed on the premise of
these pretty people you recognize are in
a place or hey it's tom cruise's head
shot and the money would just roll in
from the audiences but movie studios
were frustrated with the demands of
their powerful human movie stars in fact
that's exactly why al pacino creates
simone in the first place in the movie i
wanted to send a message
to the acting community
who
put themselves above the work
who put themselves
so it was a power struggle and the
studios wanted control eventually both
sides reached a compromise but the
damage at that point was done the
industry didn't want to be in a position
of weakness again as you've probably
noticed movie stardom isn't exactly what
it was back then these days you can be
the smartest guy in the room the most
qualified and no one cares unless you're
flying around with a cape or shooting
lasers from your hands oh sure people
can still have favorite actors and
certain famous faces can still make a
difference at the box office but
nowadays ip is king making a movie is
expensive so studios want to reduce the
risk as much as possible back in the
early 2000s studios were forced to
de-risk the movies with star power but
now it's all about de-risking using
nostalgia proven stories pre-existing ip
amazon's priciest project yet is a 465
million dollar lord of the rings
spin-off with no mega stars netflix's
biggest acquisition is the back
catalogue of roald dahl the children's
author in the absolute star-packed cast
of human actors in infinity war the
breakout role was the purple cgi raisin
man thanos that is destiny fulfilled are
robert pattinson ben affleck christian
bale michael keaton george clooney and
val kilmer all movie stars yeah in their
respective eras of prominence sure but
are any of them bigger stars than batman
and he doesn't want to drive the
batmobile and you see the great thing
about that for the studios is that they
now own the ip they own thanos they own
batman they're no longer beholden to the
actors who are in these characters roles
they are now the ones in control and
while they're in this power position why
not own the actors too disney is
confirmed to basically be assembling a
human library as the last jedi vfx
supervisor ben morris said in an
interview quote we will always digitally
scan all the lead actors in the film we
don't know if we're gonna need them we
don't intentionally scan them as an
archive process it's for reference later
but since the last jedi we know that
this process has expanded a really big
detail that i don't think a lot of
people caught in the first episode of
assembled the disney plus series that
does behind the scenes docs for various
marvel projects was this i got to do
this thing where you it's a body scan i
took pictures it's amazing even she a
relatively minor character in one of the
mcu tv projects did a full body digital
scan to be a 3d model in marvel's
character library they are keeping
digital avatars of everybody just in
case they might need to have them show
up again because at this point the actor
is completely unnecessary when you're
using this deep fake technology the face
doesn't have to be the same the body
doesn't have to be the same heck even
the voice doesn't have to be coming from
the original actor basically when you
look at virtual luke the reason he
sounds so stilted right now it's just a
smart text-to-speech bot that's learned
how to speak like a young mark hamill
something people didn't realize is that
his voice isn't real the young luke
skywalker voice is completely
synthesized it's a neural network
basically you feed uh information into
and it learns sure mark hamill posed for
some of the shots to make him feel good
about his participation but that's
exactly what it was it was all there to
make him feel good there was also a body
double doing the exact same thing and
you get a sense from these interviews
that mark hamill recognizes that he's
just an accessory in this process i was
contacted inviting me to come over and
take a look at mandalorian they said
they'd love my opinion that should have
been a giveaway right away in short we
are rapidly progressing to the future
predicted by simone to the point that
the screen actors guild feared back in
2000 we are progressing beyond needing
actors i think this line puts it best we
knew we wanted mark hamill front and
center because you can't bring back luke
skywalker without mark hamill i suppose
technologically speaking you could but
we didn't want to the actor is
completely arbitrary in the process it's
the plot of simone come to reality
obviously the reason disney keeps a
rolling out virtual luke is to train the
audience into liking it to desensitize
us into just accepting it as a viable
alternative to the real actors it's
exposure therapy it's giving us small
doses of something until we no longer
notice how weird it is you know that
disney is currently running the math on
how much it would cost him in terms of
logistics and public perception to
produce an entire film starring a
virtually reconstructed younger version
of the original star wars cast and
that's only concerning them what do you
think the odds are that we're going to
see and hear from some form of liam
neeson's qui-gon jinn in the upcoming
kenobi and beyond star wars with
ghostbusters experimenting with the
technology and afterlife can't be that
far off that we'll see the whole cast
alive and young again for the
ghostbusters 3 that we never got bit by
bit actors are just being devolved into
their characters the technology is
allowing the character to stay frozen in
time and by collecting scanned libraries
of humans these characters perpetually
sit on the shelf ready to get pulled out
for their next spin-off story it's just
more ip that the studios are adding to
their vaults and the craziest part of
all is that the actors one day might not
even need to give their consent to any
of this stuff this probably merits an
episode unto itself but very quickly the
right to publicity is the right for
someone to control how their name and
likeness is used for commercial purposes
and while many countries have rules in
place for these rights while a person's
live the idea of protecting someone
after their death is a relatively new
concept for example in the us different
states have different lengths of
protection ranging from 10 years to 100
meanwhile in the uk there's nothing
explicit there's just a few other laws
that kind of cover it when you squint
what it all amounts to is that after
someone dies you really just need one
person to approve the usage of that dead
celebrity's likeness and if you wait
even longer well technically you don't
need anyone's approval that person
basically enters the public domain to do
whatever you want with them to star in
any movie you want to sell any product
you want it's exactly what happened to
the famous dancer and actor fred astaire
in 1997 where his likeness was licensed
out by his widow to appear in vacuum
commercials leading his daughter to
complain that her father's career had
been sold to the devil the dirt devil
nothing escapes the power of a dirt
devil as homer simpson put it you people
must realize that the public owns you
for life and when you're dead you'll all
be in commercials dancing with vacuum
cleaners this is why i'm telling you
that when you look at virtual luke on
the star wars shows you're looking at
the future of all of this is it good is
it bad remains to be seen well a tool is
neither good nor bad and we try to apply
ethics to what we do where we are only
using
these tools for good studios want it
because it gives them total control they
can deliver the exact ip audiences wants
starring the exact characters they want
without having to deal with the
messiness of real actors with real
problems like aging actors may want this
it's unclear it definitely allows them
to extend their careers and profit off
continual usage of their likeness at
least until that passes over into the
public domain and mark hamill is no
longer asked to give his opinion on his
likeness's usage in the book of
mandaloria fats in audiences yeah we're
the frogs in the boiling pot right now
the heat is slowly getting turned up as
digital characters are fed to us more
and more in larger and larger roles will
we hop out of the water when it starts
to boil my guess no probably not the
studios really want this to work and if
that's all they're offering to us we'll
just keep consuming it the only question
would be well whether or not this gets
in the way of doing anything new whether
it actually stymies studios from being
forced to create new ideas and new
content when the ip that makes money
becomes that much more bulletproof new
ideas the only thing scarier than
virtual luke's deep fake face is the
idea of having to take a risk on
something new but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cut
you